älteres kind ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video
ja ich habe mir natürlich geht es gut
wäre heute was ja vor was ich schon
angekündigt habe ich weiß nicht wer von
euch das video gesehen hat indem ich
schick wurde getestet habe kurze
zusammenfassung also das ist sonne
wasser oder somit das ganze in
verschiedene flüssigkeiten geben und das
trägt dazu bei dass die flüssigkeit so
verdichtet oder verdeckt und dann hat
man so einiges klebriges wasser was man
aber tatsächlich trinken kann und das
wird angewendet weil manche menschen bei
habe ich gemerkt dass sehr viele
altenpflege haben oder das video
geschrieben das wird in der altenpflege
sehr oft eingesetzt ich will damit
natürlich ich will mich darüber nicht
lustig machen oder so was also das war
auf keinen fall so gemeint ich will halt
nun mal probieren und ja ich habe ja
schon gesagt wir testen das erste mal
mit cola fanta und milch das geht halt
auch denke ich mal ich bin echt mal
gespannt also wir haben da ich hier so
glückliche gewinner die man trinken kann
ich habe extra hier drei dieser geholt
damit man das ganze besser sehen kann
und ich würde sagen wir aber gar nicht
lange fangen direkt mal an ich bin echt
gespannt ich würde sagen wir starten
einfach mal mit der milch oder habe ich
gerade frisch gekauft schon mal ein so
das reicht ja schon
wir wollen gar nicht so viel
verschwenden dafür und jetzt greife ich
hier wieder zu dem guten alten ticken ab
instant pulver zur anlegung von
flüssigkeiten und püriertes preisen
da freue ich mich drauf suche ich auch
sehr oft gelesen leute haben geschrieben
alex kannst du nicht mal sagen wie das
schmeckt und
irgendwie habe ich mich das ein bisschen
moment so ein bisschen missverstanden
gefühlt weil das ist halt
geschmacksneutral es schmeckt nach
absolut gar nicht nur halt die
konsistenz des bisschen eklig
also welche ist ja sowieso schon ein
bisschen mit flüssiger deswegen kann ich
jetzt gar nichts ja doch es ist schon
sehr glücklich geworden also wir haben
jetzt hier irgendwie so milchpreis so
sieht es aus wie kann man das jetzt
glaube ich ganz gut sehen dass das
wirklich sehr sehr dickflüssig geworden
ist dann problem war das doch einfach
mal ich habe gerade gefrühstückt milch
zum frühstück das wären immer fester das
sieht mittlerweile schon so aus wie
einst oder leute guck mal hier rein
na ja immer schon habe ich habe jetzt
immer dicken ab milch zu meinem kaffee
trinke oder in meinem café schütte
metzger weiter
ach du scheiße
das ist wirklich das ist was geht gar
nicht klar war von der konsistenz ist es
glaube ich ein bisschen so wie pudding
der viel zu lange schon darum steht nur
es schmeckt nach nichts also dankbar
dass ich die finger von das ist nichts
für mich war das mal zur seite
okay leute machen wir weiter mit der
fanta und der cola ich glaube das machen
wir jetzt einfach mal gleichzeitig
schütte ich mal hier rein ungefähr
wieder genauso viel und dann auch hier
die cola hier bin ich jetzt mal gespannt
bei wem mehr kohlensäure
das hatte ich sonst noch nie mal schauen
oder so dass reagiert halt direkt ne ich
glaube oder das war es jetzt auch schon
es scheint sich halt so ein bisschen auf
interessant sieht es hier am rand aus
wie du wasser als nur machen
guck mal wie entsteht so viel ist der
berg das wäre doch ein gutes experiment
für chemie unterricht oder mal gucken
was jetzt mit der band passiert wir
machen hier einfach mal ein kurzes
zeitraffer
[Musik]
das war's die cola ist zusammengebrochen
wahrscheinlich passiert ist gleich das
gleiche mit der fanta das ist wie als
wenn jemand so atmen würde es geht immer
so hoch und dann fällt es wieder runter
[Musik]
ob er deutscher belasten was war dabei
als ich glaube viel mehr passierte jetzt
auch nicht dass pokert heutigen zeit so
ich kann einmal auch hier so ein
bisschen bewegen
es sieht aber finde ich schon sehr sehr
interessant aus das muss man sagen aber
viel interessanter ist jetzt natürlich
wie schmeckt das ich würde sagen wir
rühren noch einmal schön um damit sich
das alles gut verteilt können wie man
hier an
es ist halt wirklich wieso slush eis
wenn man das sieht eigentlich genauso
aus nur halt in war ich bin super
gespannt ich fange mit der fanta
anprobieren wir mal
also ich muss sagen es ist auf jeden
fall nicht lecker aber es auch nicht
eklig das problem ist man schmeckt doch
so ein bisschen jetzt dieses pulver
daraus aber ich kann nicht beschreiben
wonach es schmeckt das schmeckt halt
einfach nicht gut also empfehlen kann
ich das definitiv nicht jetzt probieren
wir mal hier die cola vielleicht ist es
daher anders
auch hier muss ich sagen alles andere
als leckerer ich weiß nicht also da hat
mir die fanta auf jeden fall von allen
sachen am besten geschmeckt dann kam die
cola dann kam die milch die milch war
wirklich total lediglich als es ist
schon wirklich nicht lecker naja leute
ich hab's probiert ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen abonniert super gerne den kanal
last dennoch um da wir sehen uns jetzt
immer von montag bis freitag immer um 17
uhr wieder jeden tag und hellwach ich
würde sagen dass war es von mir
und ja kein tor